herzlich willkommen in meiner taten welt
ist heute wieder einen klassik für euch
und zwar habe ich hier diese
schwarzwälder kirschtorte die sich ganz
viele von euch gewünscht haben
ich muss jetzt schon vorweg sagen ich
habe heute die traditionelle
schwarzwälder kirschtorte gemacht hatte
auch mit kirschwasser weil einfach der
kollege meines mannes diese torte sich
gewünscht hat und ich sehe ihn habe
backen sollen
und ich hab ich aber natürlich auch die
alkoholfreie alternative im video dann
gesagt und wehrt euch das einfach
vorstellen
es tut mir auch leid dass ich letzte
woche kein video hochgeladen habe ich
war einfach total im stress wir hatten
letzten schultag und ferien beginnen und
muss mir immer noch so viel organisieren
und ich habe auch abschied genommen von
meiner klasse ab jetzt in nächster zeit
werden mehr videos folgen allerdings
werden wir jetzt auch im urlaub sein und
ja von dort aus war auch ein paar videos
drehen und die seht ihr dann einfach ich
glaube es wird ganz geschickt dass ich
sagte wir gehen urlaub oder später
berichtete ein oder so wobei monatlich
comics holen
ja wobei wer weiß wann ich dieses video
gedreht vielleicht war es ja auch vor
fünf wochen und ich bin schon längst
wieder da und dann stehe ich da unter
wache meine wohnung mit fünf hunden und
warte auf euch ok ich glaub es mit den
ferien hat mich verraten aber egal
bei uns gibt's nix nächste hole und auf
jeden fall habe ich jetzt einfach zeigen
wie man diese schwarzwälder kirschtorte
packt das ist auch ein ganz
traditionelles rezept das habe ich von
dem konditor unser früherer nachbar war
nämlich meister konditor und da habe ich
auch ein paar meiner rezepte her bin ich
natürlich sehr dankbar und ich würde
sagen wir gehen jetzt einfach in die
küche und bauen das alles auf und ich
zeige ich erstmal die zutaten für den
biskuit teig für den bisher tag brauchen
wir sieben eier 240 gramm zucker eine
prise salz
150 gramm mehl 50 gramm kakaopulver 50 g
speisestärke und einen halben teelöffel
backpulver die eier sind auf
zimmertemperatur und die butter habe ich
zu lassen und dies jetzt auch wieder
abgekühlt
es ist ganz wichtig dass die eier
zimmertemperatur haben denn ansonsten
lassen sie sich mit dem zucker nicht so
gut aufschlagen und sie bekommen kein
großes volumen zuerst gebe ich jetzt die
eier gemeinsam mit dem zucker und dem
salz in einer rührschüssel und lasst sie
richtig schaumig schlagen
das dauert bei mir jetzt etwa 15 bis 20
minuten
ihr müsst auf jeden fall darauf achten
das ist sie wirklich so schaurig schlagt
und cremig bitte fast steif wird denn so
wird der biss gezeigt richtig schön
perfekt ich zeige euch zwischendurch
auch mal die zwischenstationen und dann
könnt ihr auch selber erkennen wie feste
masse sein soll
mit einem handrührgerät dauert das ganze
natürlich noch ein bisschen länger und
ich bitte euch auch wirklich raten das
so lange rühren zu lassen denn nur so
erhaltet ihr eine richtig schöne luftige
form
jetzt könnte man meinen dass es schon
reicht aber wie ihr sehen könnt ist das
ganze noch ziemlich flüssig zwar schon
schön cremig aber wir werden weiter
schlagen
das hat jetzt ungefähr fünf minuten
gestartet nach etwa 15 minuten sieht
jetzt die masse so aussieht sie läuft
immer noch von einem schneebesen runter
und hat deutlich an volumen zugenommen
und ist auch viel fester geworden
ich lasse jetzt noch fünf minuten
schlagen und es lohnt sich auch wirklich
also lasst sie wirklich so lange
schlagen
ich sehe es
bis sie einfach was nicht mehr runter
läuft zum schluss sollte die masse dann
so aussehen so dass wir eben was gar
nicht mehr runter tropft dann ist sie
perfekt und jetzt können wir die
trockenen zutaten nehmen also mehr
speisestärke kakaopulver und backpulver
und 7 das hinein und jetzt wird es
einfach mit einem schneebesen ganz
vorsichtig untergehoben immer auf dem
außen nach innen und das machen wir
jetzt ganz vorsichtig so dass die luft
die wir jetzt mühsam eingeschlagen haben
dass wir die nicht wieder gleich raus
schlagen könnt auch im teig schaber
nehmen
dann nehmen wir die flüssige butter und
heben die jetzt auch noch unter
und jetzt nehme ich hier meinen
vorbereiteten trotten ring ich habe ihn
einfach auf einem backblech geben und
ihnen auf 26 cm eingestellt das ist
dieser verstellbare back rahmen
und da fühle ich jetzt den tag hinein
so werde ich ihnen jetzt bei 190 grad
für etwa 25 bis 35 minuten backen
je nach backofen und wird dann natürlich
ein stäbchen probe machen
so sieht der teig jetzt bei mir nach 25
minuten backzeit aus und ihr könnt sehen
bei der stäbchen wo bleibt nichts mehr
am zahnstocher hängen
das heißt der teig ist klar dass ihnen
hier kurz etwa zwei minuten april und
berlin dann stürzen
jetzt nehme ich mir einen tortenring
messer und werterhalt den torten rand
lösen
jetzt lege ich da ein tuch drauf
und beide mit hilfe von diesem zweiten
rettern einmal oben und einmal unten
den teig jetzt stürzen
und ich werde jetzt einfach abdecken
abkühlen lassen und ging dann nach dem
abkühlen noch mal für etwa eine halbe
stunde in den kühlschrank der
tortenboden ist jetzt richtig schön kalt
ich habe ihn im kühlschrank gehabt und
so bröselt er auch weniger beim
schneiden
ich nehme es ihr so einfach meint orten
schneider
denn so kann ich auch direkt zwei bilden
auf einmal durchschneiden
ich schaue man ob das von der
einstellung her passt und so würde ich
jetzt den teig durchschneiden
jetzt nehme ich mir eine tortenplatte
und schiebt das ganze darüber und ich
las den teig jetzt auch gestürzt also
das war ja vorher der boden
ich habe ja den kuchen umgedreht und ich
möchte dass das jetzt auch oben bleibt
weil es hier schön eben ist
jetzt kann ich hier die beiden
unternehmen und den oberen nämlich auch
gleich weg um die einzelnen bögen jetzt
zu tränken brauchen wir 20 gramm zucker
20 gramm wasser und 100 milliliter
kirschwasser da könnte jetzt dieses
original schwarzwälder kirschwasser
nehmen
das wäre dann eben für die traditionelle
und originale schwarzwälder kirschtorte
deswegen heißt es hier auch so weil man
da eben kirschwasser benutzt das ist
natürlich alkoholisch wenn er aber auf
alkohol verzichten wollte oder möchte
ich dann bin ich einfach etwas
kirschsaft und dann könnt ihr euch auch
den vorgang mit dem zucker mit dem
wasser sparen sondern einfach 100
milliliter geschafft nehmen und damit
die böden tränken
ich nehme jetzt das schwarzwälder
kirschwasser reicht die torte
verschenken muss und sich die person
einfach die original torte gewünscht hat
in den kleinen topf gebe ich jetzt den
zucker gemeinsam mit dem wasser
und lasst es schön aufkochen bis sich
der zucker gelöst hat danach könnt ihr
den herd ausschalten und gebt dann noch
das kirschwasser mit es werden einfach
alle drei bilden damit getränkt einfach
mit einem pinsel über die oberfläche
fahren
für die kühlung brauchen wir ein glas
sauerkirsche die haben in der regel 680
gramm davon brauchen wir die kirschen
und den saft wir brauchen 45 g
speisestärke ihr könnt aber auch eine
tüte vanillepudding kuba nehmen aber ich
sage man spart euch das geld nimmt
einfach speisestärke das nämlich viel
günstiger und hat auch keine
zusatzstoffe eine gute prise zimt 60
gramm zucker und den saft einer halben
zitrone die kirchen gieße ich jetzt
einfach mal ab und fangen den saft hier
in meinem topf auf den herd könnt ihr
dann auch gleich abschalten auf höchste
stufe sind kommt gleich mit rein zucker
zitronensaft
und auch gleich die stärke und jetzt
alles schönkirchen freiwilligen und
einfach jetzt ruhen bis das ganze kocht
und sobald dieser hirsch pudding dann
kocht wieder auch schon günstig dann
gebt ihr gleich die kirchen mit dazu das
wird das ganze noch mal stellung
jetzt kann man den herrn ausschalten
damit ist jetzt am topfboden nichts
angelegt und anderen und so sind die
kirschen jetzt schon fertig abgebunden
das will ich die kirchen zum abkühlen
einfach hier rein aus dem heißen topf
heraus und lass dir kurz stehen bis sie
nicht mehr heiß sind
jetzt nehme ich hier meine kirsch
füllung und geht nach erreichen und beim
verstreichen achte ich darauf dass ich
ringsherum einen zentimeter freilassen
so einem kleinen ring freilasse also ich
hab das jetzt nicht glatt aufgetragen
sondern eher so ein bisschen kugelförmig
und so gebe ich den teig jetzt nochmal
in den kühlschrank und wird in dieser
zeit meine sahne vorbereiten für die
sahen erfüllung brauchen wir 700
milliliter kalte schlagsahne die ständig
jetzt auch vielleicht wieder kühl
hier habe ich 25 gramm von dem
kirschwasser und wie gesagt auch hier
könnt ihr kirschwasser durch herrschaft
austauschen 65 gramm zucker könnte auch
gerne etwas weniger nehmen und ich habe
hier einen halbtoten ak tine und aktive
kennt ihr ja bereit ihr könnt natürlich
auch gelatine nehmen dann etwa neun
blätter
denn eine tüte akademie entspricht 6
platine und reicht für 500 milliliter
und da ich jetzt hier 700 habe nehme ich
jetzt etwa 15 gramm
von dieser kabine
und bei der akademie ist es etwas anders
als bei der gelatine
hier brauchen wir 200 gramm wasser um
desktops aufzukochen denn nur so
entfaltet sie ihre wirkung
die ak tine gebe ich jetzt gemeinsam mit
dem wasser in den topf und berühren und
auf höchster stufe aufkochen lassen
danach muss sie für zwei minuten lang
kochen damit sie ihre wirkung entfaltet
und dann lasse ich sie ganz kurz
abkühlen
in der zwischenzeit werde ich schon mal
die sahne steif schlagen das mache ich
jetzt in der kenwood weil die einfach
ein spritzschutz hat wo einfach der
komplette deckel zu ist und mir so
einfach die sonne nicht aus dem rohr
behältnis raus spritzt da gebe ich dann
auch den zucker mit dazu und natürlich
das kirschwasser oder den kirschsaft und
jetzt gebe ich etwas von der saane masse
zu dieser ad linie dazu und verwies
damit die athener einfach auf temperatur
kommt wenn wir sie jetzt nämlich so
komplett in die saane kippen würden dann
bekommt ihr kleines stückchen in der
sahne und betreiben und das war nicht so
schön
jetzt gebe ich diese akazie seine masse
hier dazu um einen tortenboden habe ich
jetzt auch noch mal meinen ring gegeben
und jetzt gebe ich einfach die hälfte
der creme in die torte streich so schön
partie gibt dann den mittleren boden
drauf
du bist meine immer schön glatt
streichen so dankeschön und jetzt die
restliche creme oben drauf und dann
kommt einfach noch der deckel obendrauf
wird auch schön an gedrückt und ihr seht
jetzt auch die torte ist ziemlich hoch
geworden der tortenring ist insgesamt
zehn zentimeter hoch also ist meine
schwarzwälder jetzt ungefähr neun
zentimeter hoch da brauchte auf jeden
fall den hohen tortenring und so gebe
ich jetzt einfach für mindestens 4
stunden besser noch über nacht abgedeckt
am besten mit dieser tortenplatte in den
kühlschrank
meine torte weiß für etwa fünf stunden
im kühlschrank und jetzt werde ich sie
noch fertig stellen ich muss jetzt
gleichsam aufschlagen damit die torte
dekorieren kann und ich werde jetzt noch
schoko späne herstellen das zeigt ich
einfach mal ihr braucht dafür nämlich
nur 100 gramm zartbitterschokolade das
ist jetzt auch keine kuvertüre sondern
einfach schokolade und jetzt nehme ich
mir ein tablett hier also ein brettchen
und ein scharfes messer lehnt das ganze
thema meine hüfte hier an den bauch und
sie einfach die röllchen ab und habe
dann schöne schoko späne also die hier
würde ich dann benutzen um die torte
obendrauf zu dekorieren
da ziehe ich mir jetzt einfach einige ab
sonst setzt sie auf eine platte wenn ihr
euch das und unterlegten feuchtes dann
rutscht das auch nicht
diese schönen langen späne benutze ich
jetzt um die torte obendrauf zu
dekorieren und jetzt aus dieser
restlichen schokolade
ihr könnt es auch hier sehen die sind
ganz dünn geworden aus der mache ich
jetzt noch ganz kurze späne und zwar
benutze ich da jetzt die makro pläne
dafür könnt ihr einfach eine ganz
normale reibe nehmen weil vollmilch
schokolade schmeckt einfach viel zu süß
und die zarte schokolade schmeckt
natürlich viel schokoladiger weil sie
hinein hören kakaoanteil hat ich habe
jetzt die schokolade fein gehackt und
werde jetzt noch die sahne steif
schlagen
ich habe ziehe 300 gramm plane und jetzt
könnt ihr entweder wieder mit ak tine
oder gelatine arbeiten
ich werde jetzt allerdings an apart
nehmen das kennt ihr ja bereits schon
aus meinen videos
ihr könnt aber auch sahnesteif benutzen
weil ich hatte sahen jetzt gleich weiter
verwenden wer hatte möchte ich dass er
schnell fest wird deswegen nehme ich
jetzt einfach seiner partei ak tine geht
genauso und gelatine da muss man einfach
kurz warten bis die magazine und
gelatine weg so dass die sache fest dass
man sie auf spritzen kann ich nehme da
jetzt etwa zwei teelöffel sonderfahrt
und schlag ist einfach die sahne steif
das kennt er bereits
und dann könnte die sahne einfach in den
spritzbeutel füllen ihr habt ihr gesehen
ich habe da schon so eine rosetten thüle
drauf und ich verlinke euch natürlich
einfach alle produkte und neben einer
infobox unten wo ihnen vor steht die
torte ist jetzt gekühlt das heißt ich
kann jetzt auch den ring abnehmen und
normalerweise geht es auch so genau
ohne dass ich den ring jetzt öffnen muss
ja kannst du leider nicht probieren die
wird verschenkt ich mach dir wieder ein
jetzt nehme ich mir etwas sahne und
spritzt sich hier am rand entlang
einfach damit ich sie gleich schön
verstreichen
jetzt kann ich mir einfach so eine type
karte nehmen und das am rand hier schön
verstreichen
und aus dem grund empfehle ich euch
immer eine drehbare trocken platte es
sieht man das ist einfach viel einfacher
und handlicher jetzt schon ein bisschen
sahne obendrauf und etwas glatt
streichen
und es geht natürlich auch mit einem
langen messer aber so ein paletten
messer eignet sich natürlich besser
geschmeckt grob und dann nehme ich mein
langes anzunehmen da einfach das
paletten messer und streicht von außen
nach innen
jetzt kann ich hier bei dem toten
drehteller die neigung verändern und das
ist jetzt prima weil ich jetzt nämlich
die schokolade hier am rahmen strand
setzen will
das heißt ich kann jetzt hier immer
etwas schokolade nehmen mir auf diese
palette auf dieses top diese teig karte
geben und einfach von unten nach oben an
drücken
so werden auch die hände nicht dreckig
mit schokolade denn sobald ihr die
schokolade in die hand nimmt schmilzt
die und da habt ihr keine chance
vor allem nicht bei den temperaturen
wird kann ich wieder hier zurück drehen
alte falsche richtung
jetzt mache ich hier natürlich erstmal
den rand sauber und da oben auch
gleichmäßig also da könnte da noch ein
bisschen schokolade datensätzen über
alles soweit habt kommt noch die schoko
späne in die mitte komm her
die können jetzt am besten auch mit der
teig herunterziehen ich möchte mich
nicht dass sie schmelzen
schön in die mitte und jetzt könnt ihr
hier auch die späne verteilen
und jetzt kommen darauf seine kupfer
drauf ich mache immer erst mal so einmal
gegenüber
übergroß anziehen genau
und jetzt kommt es darauf an wollt ihr
16 oder zwölf stück ja wir machen jetzt
12 und jetzt kommen diese belegt hier
schon drauf die gibt es eigentlich auch
in jedem supermarkt in der buck
abteilung mir persönlich schmecken die
nicht so gut weil die einfach total süß
sind aber sondern schwarzwälder
kirschtorte gehören natürlich die
kirchen dazu ich habe auch mal ganz
normaler sauerkirschen genommen wenn ihr
frische kirschen habt könnt ihr die gern
nehmen
bei den sauerkirschen aus dem glas tritt
da gern mal dann der fruchtsaft aus aber
wenn sie vorher auf dem küchentrakt
abtropfen lassen
ich hab das auch super ich mache die
immer gern so ein bisschen in den rand
nicht ganz oben in die mitte
so ganz vergessen ja so sieht jetzt die
fertigen schwarzwälder kirschtorte aus
ich denke ich werde später noch mit
kleines video von dem anschnitt machen
wie sie von innen aussieht aber da ich
sie jetzt wahrscheinlich muss ich sie
leider im ganzen mitnehmen und das
rezept gibt es natürlich auf meinem blog
ich würde mich natürlich freuen wenn in
den kommentar der last wenn ihr euch
auch einen anderen klassiker man wünscht
klassiker klassiker wahl wünscht ich
habe auf jeden fall auch ein frankfurter
kranz machen dass ich auch so einer
meiner lieblings classics und auch die
schwarzwälder kirschtorte und mag ich
sehr gerne und ja vielleicht habt ihr
die auch schon mal gemacht und ich würde
mich auf jeden fall auf eure kommentare
freuen
auch auf eure bewertung unfalls ist noch
nicht getan habt könnt ihr mich auch
gerne abonnieren
und zwar geht es ganz leicht hier oben
und das ist kostenlos und bleibt auch
kostenlos als er für all diejenigen die
das nicht kennen ja da freue ich mich
über drüber und wir sehen uns dann
einfach beim nächsten mal wieder
gespielt
damit geht es nicht doch dafür ist ja
nett wenn er die tat kriegen er wenn er
die torte mit kinderschokolade kriegst
du darfst du erst murat
jetzt wissen alle was seine tiger ist
für mich auch so ein werkzeug was ich
echt nicht mehr wissen möchte teigs aber
vielfach maschine eine parkscheibe kann
ich auch nehmen kann ich ja mein
nächstes mal probiert wird noch mal was
in europa geschah weil mein bruder mal
da muss das ambiente kindergarten
bringen im winter und der hat halt kein
eis grad sondern habe ich ihnen nur
karte gegeben und ich hoffe nie wieder
gekriegt aber egal ich habe noch genug